oui cette réduction de 27 ans à 25 pour
l'âge de la mobilisation obligatoire
n'est que l'un des éléments dans un
projet de loi qui vise aussi à limiter
la durée du service militaire à 3 ans
pour peut-être donner un peu plus
d'enthousiasme à des gens pour pour les
convaincre que ce sera pour une période
limitée mais aussi qui vise à augmenter
les peines pour ceux qui cherch
chercherai à esquiver à la mobilisation
pour aussi rendre plus clair les
procédures que tout ukrainien doit
suivre pour être sûr qu'il est sur les
listes et peut-être suivre des
formations de base mais en réalité il
n'est toujours pas clair même s'il est
possible que le projet de loi soit voté
en première lecture aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui sera dans ce projet de loi
même cet après-midi puisque il doit
passer encore en comité parlementaire ce
matin et presque de tous les bords
politiques il est très vivement critiqué
par des partis d'opposition mais aussi
par le parti de voladimir Zelenski
serviteur du peuple qui hier a dit que
il n'était pas satisfait du texte et que
probablement il faudrait le retravailler
avant de passer au vote alors il est
très probable que le vote soit remis à
plus tard peut-être seulement à demain
mais peut-être à plus tard encore grande
inquiétude en Ukraine même si euh ce
renouveau du débat politique avec
beaucoup de voix discordante témoigne en
quelque sorte de la démocratie qui est
toujours toujours fonctionnante en
quelque sorte dans le pays clairement
c'est aussi une risque de montrer une
certaine faiblesse et une manque d'unité
et de
détermination si l'Ukraine n'arrive pas
à passer cette loi clairement très très
nécessaire suffisamment rapidement alors
que la guerre bonjour gulivers se
poursuit un deux missiles russes se sont
abattus à carquive dans dans le nord-est
du pays ces dernières heures près d'un
hôtel particulièrement connu des
journalistes étrangers
oui il s'agit du Parc Hôtel harkive
vraiment c'est l'hôtel des journalistes
en quelque sorte dans la ville en tout
cas pour ceux qui n'avaient pas les
moyens de ce loger au harkiv Palace qui
a été lui frappé le 30 décembre dernier
alors c'estes deux grands hôtels
fréquentés par les journalistes
étrangers à harkiv qui ont été frappés
au moin moins de de semaines clairement
c'est inquiétant on ne peut pas dire
avec certitude si c'était vraiment
l'hôtel qui était visé ou un bâtiment à
côté mais le fait que il y a un délai si
petit après la frappe sur l'autre hôtel
cela semble assez probable et donc je
pense qu'il faut conclure que cela
pourrait aurait pu être bien pire
puisque les missiles se sont abattus à
côté de l'hôtel et non pas sur l'hôtel
les dégâts sont impressionnés je pense
que vous voyez les images de la façade
de l'hôtel mais il y a un bâtiment
beaucoup plus grand en fait derrière
cette façade multi-étage c'est là que la
plupart des chambres se trouvent alors
là c'est seulement la partie devant de
l'hôtel qui a été frappé les voitures
beaucoup de voitures dans le parking ont
été détruit mais selon les autorités
locales le nombre de blessés est de 13
seulement et il n'y a pas de mort à
déployer je pense que parmi ces blessés
ces deux qui sont blessés grav et il y a
des employés de l'hôtel et des clients
de l'hôtel parmi ces blessés Guliver
Krag à Kief merci beaucoup guiliver
autre guerre autre